good old-fashioned goats and the ancient
Hindu practice of yoga two things that
don't seem to go together you got peanut
butter on my chocolate but one year ago
a small farm in Oregon invented goat
yoga and the unlikely trend spread
across the nation until it reached the
east coast when the unstoppable force of
goat yoga met the immovable object of
the Washington DC Department of Health
[Music]
goat yo guys literally we do yoga as a
class 40 minutes and we just had the
goats hang out with us so we would go
through the different asanas and
different flows and the goats will come
around and interact with people as we
were doing the class so they may walk up
to somebody and sip their nose maybe
nibble on some toes and if they're
feeling brave enough or want to they
might jump on them or give a kiss or
something DC is not very livestock
oriented I know that it was a big thing
with Health Department though they asked
us to do a lot of things with our vet
certifications health certificates and
things like that we did everything they
asked and they ended up squashing it
anyway
[Music]
congressional cemetery is a historic
Cemetery founded in 1807
it is a private Cemetery home to about a
hundred and sixty markers for individual
congressmen we opened up our chapel
every Wednesday night to a yoga
instructor we call it yoga mortis then
there are some who find their inner
peace next to dead people
corpse pose we've had goats to eat all
of our invasive species in our forested
area of the cemetery so we thought why
not combine baby goats and yoga we knew
we would need a permit for that because
we're bringing in livestock into the
district and so we went to the
Department of Health to obtain that
permit and when I went down to meet with
them it was a big conference room the
director was there which kind of
surprised me and about four lawyers were
there with all of the rules and
regulations open on their laptops ready
to kind of throw every curveball they
possibly could at me to prevent goat
yoga
[Music]
goats have been domesticated for about
6,000 years but they required that we
obtain a wildlife handlers certificate
for our goat farmer they initially were
worried that someone would fall during a
yoga class or an exercise and hurt a
baby goat which is really difficult to
do if you've ever been around a herd of
goats especially babies they are
constantly falling down jumping on each
other jumping on rocks really having the
time of their life but what if the goats
are not having the time of their lives
what if the Department of Health was
right when he told Washingtonian
magazine any time animals come into the
district we want to make sure they are
safe and not being put into a position
of harm expressing concern for the
safety of animals should someone ever
fall over one and demon goat yoga a
violation of a No Touch policy by
spectators for animals participating in
district events
[Music]
Mount Vernon Square neighborhood had a
petting zoo for youngsters and they had
far more exotic animals than goats they
even had Obama which is a pretty vile
animal if you've ever been around a
spitting llama but they allowed a lot of
this no-touching to actually happen at
that petting zoo there's no reason that
you can't do goat yoga great there's no
[Music]
you